now i'm going to use everything I knew
before about multiplication and division
of functions okay i'm going to use it on
this okay so the first thing is and in a
rough picture Oh what am i dealing with
what am i doing okay I know what X looks
like and I know log X looks like
independently so let's put them on there
[Music]
there's like this okay so just like
Jeanette along with in addition and
subtraction of functions if you want the
whole thing to exist then all of the
components also need to eaters so tell
me what's happening 4x is less than zero
answer nothing is happening more and x
is less than zero right because you're
like oh it's this guy x undefined okay
so so therefore you don't have to worry
about that okay all right what about
what's happening in here what do you see
a mai tai okay remember i'm multiplying
key okay so this is a bit trickier than
what I had before but here's what I'm
gonna try and pull out for you okay the
first example let's do it easy if its
first easy bits first okay so over here
over here what's happening here I
multiply these two together right so
this point here which is by the way x
equals 11 y equal 0 ok I've got 0 times
something else do I care what that
something else is not really okay so
therefore I'm going to pass through
there right you multiply 0 by whatever
your gives you all right what about to
the right to the right okay what's
happening when you multiply these
numbers by these notes well number one I
know about the sign okay so there's
going to be positive stuff happening
here now keep in mind y equals x it's
growing y equals log X also growing it's
slowing down but still growing no stops
so when you put them together what you
should expect is something that's
steeper than both of them do you see
that right so it wouldn't make sense for
this to be also a straight line cuz
you've got a straight line and you're
multiplying by bigger and bigger numbers
okay so therefore it's good to curve
upwards like that has to curve upwards I
should choose a better color okay does
it touch what do you think yeah I think
it must be cuz there's only two ways
that it cannot touch number water could
be parallel like that well number two
could lean away they can't possibly do
that you're multiplying this number by a
number that's positive and getting
bigger so it's going to get bigger as
well you say the
life on your own is a reflection of no
I'm not saying that um it's implausible
that it is but i don't really i haven't
analyzed it to that death to read it
does certainly looks sort of like that
book alright so we're down going what's
going on here that was the easy part
what's happening in here now let's just
pull back what we know from those guys
right after the minimum that I know is
between x equals 10 x equals 0 I have a
positive value times some negative
values right so at least I know it's got
to be down here it's gotta be down here
okay so i know i'm going to slide in
down here okay hmm now here's another
tricky question this one i'm going to
use some values users right so remember
we said this is x equals 1 so that means
on this line but y value that
corresponds to it is y equals 1 yes so
that means all of the ordinates all of
the ordinance in here do you see they're
all less than 1 they're like three
quarters or half or a third they're all
smaller than one we multiply a number by
something is less than one what happens
to your original against one right so
this number down here is getting
multiplied by something that's smaller
than one so it's going to shrink it's
going to shrink now does it go down here
does lucky you see there's a tug of war
right does log X which is pulling down
when orders x which is going to 0 when
instead
[Music]
okay now how are we going to work
yourself okay well this is tricky okay
you've got color tools your disposal if
this one wins if the zero wins right
that means that this has got to go down
and come back up what feature is that
cool that's our that's a turning point
as a stationary could I find such a
thing there's going to let you in right
now number one I think we could number
two I can actually work out the toilet
even without resorting to calculus right
because remember I just need a picture
state a picture I don't have to find an
elegant way to get the picture even an
inelegant way is fine okay you remember
when I said to you and then when i said
to you hey extremities it's journeys put
in some huge challenges but it's go on
go for it right well I'm not going to
put huge values in here am I I'm going
to put in one tiny world so for example
let's just put in 0.1 let's try that so
for example i'm now texting right so
what is 0.1 long 0.1 that's X log X
right what's it equal to what do you get
Priya decimal
someone up this one point okay that's
fine that's still in this region here
that I expected let's try something
smaller 0.01 all right long 0.0 what's
happening who's winning my face why coz
X is winning cuz look as I get closer
and closer we would actually say the way
I would formally right this is that the
limit as X approaches 0 of X log X
clearly it's approaching zero you see
that and the closer you get the more 0
it will be the limit is 0 ok started
missing so therefore I'm going to be
coming up to this point near the origin
ok except i'll never get there can
someone tell me why i can never get to
the origin correct we we bump into that
domain restriction we had right at the
beginning log X doesn't exist for that
value so there's a hollow circle death
ok but everywhere else you're going to
get values and like that and it has to
it has to come back up because you've
got to get that intercept do you see
you've got some negative values in here
and then you're going to climb back up
to y equals zero